the Irish contestant Alexander emini is
an avid tennis player he has invented a
software that analyzes tennis tropes and
gives detailed feedback to athletes so
that they can improve their performance
right now my my algorithm is monitoring
the inertial data from the center and
until I hit a stroke it will once I hit
the stroke it will detect the stroke and
then try and process each of the
possible stroke types I could have
possibly been hit once the stroke is a
process is the process by it's provided
back to the athlete by feedback and also
precise and unbiased feedback is
provided based on small deviations that
were performed and that could be used to
improve the stroke for the next time
though if a